THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
FIREWORKS IN A HIGH-STAKES
OVAL OFFICE MEETING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND TOP
DEMOCRATS NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER CLASHING OVER
BORDER WALL FUNDING AND AVOIDING
A PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IN
A HEATED FACE-OFF.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE THESE.
THE WALL, THAT WILL BE THE
EASIEST OF ALL, WHAT DO YOU
THINK, CHUCK?
>> IT IS CALLED FUNDING THE
GOVERNMENT, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> YOU HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE THE SENATE.
YOU HAVE THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
THE FACT IS YOU DO NOT HAVE THE
VOTES IN THE HOUSE.
>> NANCY, I DO.
WE NEED BORDER SECURITY.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS
OF THE EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
BORDER SECURITY, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE JOB WE'RE DOING --
>> YOU JUST SAID IT IS
EFFECTIVE.
>> CAN I TELL YOU SOMETHING.
WITHOUT A WALL, CHUCK, YOU SHUT
IT DOWN.
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DO WHAT YOU
DID.
>> YOU SAID I WILL SHUTDOWN THE
GOVERNMENT IF I DON'T GET MY
WALL.
>> DO YOU WANT TO KNOW
SOMETHING?
>> YOU SAID IT.
>> I WILL TAKE IT.
I AM PROUD TO SHUTDOWN THE
GOVERNMENT FOR BORDER SECURITY.
I WILL TAKE THE MANTLE.
I WILL BE THE ONE TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
I WON'T BLAME YOU FOR IT.
THE LAST TIME YOU SHUT IT DOWN,
DIDN'T WORK.
I WILL TAKE THE MANTLE OF
SHUTTING IT DOWN AND I WILL SHUT
IT DOWN FOR BORDER SECURITY.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS POUNCING ON
THE PRESIDENT, SAYING THAT HE
WOULD BE PROUD TO SHUTDOWN THE
GOVERNMENT OVER BORDER WALL.
BUT HE'S REFUSING TO BACK DOWN.
>> I DON'T MIND HAVING THE ISSUE
BORDER SECURITY ON MY SIDE.
IF WE HAVE TO CLOSE DOWN THE
SECURITY OVER BORDER SECURITY, I
WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE THAT IN
TERMS OF AN ISSUE.
CHUCK'S PROBLEM IS THAT ONLY
LAST CLOSED DOWN, THAT WAS HIS
IDEA.
AND HONESTLY, HE GOT KILLED.
SO HE DOESN'T WANT TO OWN IT AND
I SAID YOU KNOW RATHER THAN US
DEBATING WHO IS OWNING IT, I
WILL TAKE IT.
I WILL TAKE IT.
IF WE CLOSE DOWN THE COUNTRY, I
WILL TAKE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: JESSE, THE MEETING
WAS MOSTLY SHOW NO MATTER WHAT,
RIGHT?
>> Jesse: THAT WAS ALL
SUBSTANCE.
>> Dana: INTERESTING.
BOTH SIDES FEEL IT COULD NOT
HAVE GONE BETTER.
>> Jesse: IF YOU ARE DEMOCRAT,
YOU SAY TRUMP IS TAKEN FROM A
POSSIBILITY FOR THE TRUMP
SHUTDOWN AND IF YOUR TRUMP, YOU
LOOK AT THE VIDEO AND SAY I
MANHANDLED THESE TWO PEOPLE ON
LIVE TELEVISION AND THEY
LOOK LIKE COMPLETE BUFFOONS.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE BODY
LANGUAGE THERE, HE WAS CUTTING
THEM OFF.
HE WAS HOLDING A PIECE OF PAPER.
NANCY, NANCY, NANCY.
CHUCK SITTING THERE LIKE A
WEAKLING.
NANCY GETTING INTERRUPTED THE
WHOLE TIME.
IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY PHYSICAL
PERFORMANCE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, LOOK, ON
A DEBATE STAGE, HE DID THE SAME
THING WITH HILLARY.
BUT THESE ARE TWO WEAKER PEOPLE
AND HE BASICALLY TAG TEAMED BOTH
OF THEM UNTIL THEY LOOKED LIKE
BLITHERING IDIOTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE SAID I
AM SHUTTING THIS TIME FOR BORDER
SECURITY AND I DON'T CARE IF I
TAKE THE HEAT.
THIS IS THE LAST CHANCE HE'S
EVER GOING TO HAVE TO GET THE
WALL FUNDING.
IT'S EITHER DO-OR-DIE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO GET IT IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AND HE MAY NOT
GET IT IN THE NEXT SIX.
HE HAS TO GO TO THE MAT ON THIS.
HE HAS TO OWN THE ISSUE.
IF HE DOESN'T GET IT, HIS
SUPPORTERS ARE GOING TO SHOW UP
IN THE GENERAL AND SAY YOU KNOW
IT, YOU HAD FOUR YEARS TO BUILD
A WALL AND DIDN'T BRING IT
TOGETHER.
>> Dana: TO THAT POINT, GREG,
THERE WAS A NPR MARIST POLL.
THERE WAS A CHART.
>> Greg: TELL ME.
>> Dana: THEY ASKED
REPUBLICANS SHEEDY COMPROMISE ON
THE WALL FUNDING AND LEARN TO
AVOID A SHUTDOWN, REPUBLICAN
SAID DO NOT COMPROMISE.
HE HAS THAT ON HIS SIDE.
>> Greg: CAN YOU PULL UP THE
PICTURE OF THE GROUP?
WE ARE MISSING THE BIGGEST STORY
HERE WHICH IS PENCE WHO HAS BEEN
CRYOGENICALLY FROZEN.
THEY TALK ABOUT, THEY SHOULD
HAVE A BODY LANGUAGE EXPERT DO
THAT TO PENCE.
THERE IS NOBODY THERE.
IT'S JUST PURE AND ELECTRONIC.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I WOULD DO
BECAUSE I'M GOING YOU KNOW WHAT,
STAYING OUT OF THIS.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT THE PENCE
SHUTDOWN.
>> Greg: I'M NOT INVOLVED.
I DON'T HANG OUT WITH WOMEN WHO
AREN'T MY WIFE.
I'M NOT GETTING INVOLVED.
I AM STAYING OUT OF TROUBLE.
THIS ENCAPSULATES TWO THINGS.
WHY WE HATE TRIBAL POLITICS.
THERE IS A SOLUTION IN FRONT OF
THIS.
YOU DO THIS.
WE'LL DO THAT.
THERE IS A SOLUTION THERE BUT
THEY CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE EVEN IF
THEY AGREE WITH WHAT TRUMP IS
DOING, THEY CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE
IT'S TRUMP.
BORDER SECURITY IS IMPORTANT BUT
THEY CAN'T ADMIT IT.
THE CHALLENGE FOR TRUMP IS THAT
HE'S ALWAYS CHOOSING THE
LONG-TERM BENEFIT THAT CREATES
SHORT-TERM PUBLIC RELATIONS
NIGHTMARES.
THIS MAKES HIM LOOK MEAN.
THE SHUTDOWN MAKES HIM LOOK MEAN
BUT THE LONG TERM WIN IS
ENHANCED BORDER SECURITY WHICH
IS LIKE NATIONAL SECURITY, LAW
AND ORDER, YOU TAKE THE
LONG-TERM VISION.
BUT YOU GET REAMED OVER THE
STUFF.
>> Dana: JUAN, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT PELOSI SAID TO THE
PRESIDENT WAS YOU HAVE
MAJORITIES IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE UNTIL NEXT MONTH.
YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENCY.
YOU PAST THE $5 BILLION.
NOW THERE IS TALK ON THE HILL
THAT HOUSE REPUBLICANS MIGHT TRY
TO PASS IT.
I THOUGHT, WHY DIDN'T THEY DO IT
BEFORE?
>> Juan: I THINK THAT'S WHAT
NANCY PELOSI WAS SAYING, AND HE
WAS COMING BACK AND SAYING WE
DON'T HAVE THE VOTES IN THE
SENATE WHERE THEY NEED 60.
HE WAS MISSING THE POINT TOTALLY
THAT HE COULD IN FACT ESTABLISH
THE BASELINE FROM WHICH
NEGOTIATIONS TAKE PLACE BY
HAVING A VOTE AMONG THE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE.
I THINK IT INDICATES THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY THINK THEY
HAVE THE VOTES IN THE HOUSE
RIGHT NOW.
THAT BECAME APPARENT I THINK,
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT
ENCOURAGED HARD-LINERS IN THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS TODAY TO SAY
UNLESS IT'S GOT MY WALL, 100%,
THE $5 BILLION, DON'T GO ALONG
WITH IT.
AS YOU POINT OUT IN THE NPR
POLL, APPARENTLY A MAJORITY OF
THE TRUMP PARTY PEOPLE SAY
THAT'S THE CASE.
I MUST SAY THE REST OF THE POLL
WAS OVERWHELMING IN TERMS OF
AMERICAN SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT.
>> Dana: BUT IF EVERYONE WAS
POSTURING TODAY, THE FIRST
MEETING, I DON'T THINK ALL OF
THEM ARE GOING TO BE ON
TELEVISION.
YOU DON'T NEGOTIATE ALL YOUR
GOOD STUFF IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS.
MAYBE THEY WILL.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE'LL SEE.
WHERE DO YOU THINK IT GOES FROM
HERE?
>> Morgan: I THINK THE BIG
WINNER TODAY WAS SCHUMER'S PRESS
SECRETARY.
I WAS A PRESS SECRETARY BEFORE,
NOT AS HIGH-PROFILE AS YOU, BUT
SCHUMER KEPT GOING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THE SAME POINTS, TRYING TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT IT WAS THAT
TRUMP SHUTDOWN AND WE GOT THE
PRESIDENT TO SAY, HE HAD TO
STRETCH OUR GRIN ON HIS FACE
LIKE HE WAS SO HAPPY -- CHESHIRE
GRIN ON HIS FACE LIKE HE WAS SO
HAPPY.
THE THING THAT PEOPLE LIKED
ABOUT BERNIE AND TRUMP, NO
MATTER WHAT PARTY YOU CAME FROM,
IT'S THE ULTIMATE DISRUPTING
POLITICS.
INSTEAD OF EVERYONE GETTING IN
FRONT OF THE PRESS AND
PRETENDING LIKE THEY ALL GET
ALONG AND LIKE EACH OTHER, THEY
ALL JUST THREW IT OUT THERE.
IT WAS LIKE WWE.
IT WAS NASTY, DISRUPTIVE.
BUT I THINK THAT'S GOOD FOR
POLITICS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT OUR FOUNDERS
INTENDED.
THEY DIDN'T ATTEND FOR EVERYONE
TO PLAY NICE.
>> Jesse: THE FOUNDERS WANTED
A WALL, I THINK THAT WAS THE
CASE.
FEDERALIST 41.
>> Juan: I MUST SAY IF IT WAS
WWE E OR LET'S SAY A BOXING
MATCH AND YOU WERE SCORING, THE
IDEA WAS HE SAYS I WANT A
SHUTDOWN.
I OWN IT.
NOBODY DOES THAT.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY HE WON.
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T THINK
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT'S,
CAUSE THAT MUCH PAIN TO REGULAR
PEOPLE.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA
BECOME HYSTERICAL WHEN THERE'S A
SHUTDOWN BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THE GOVERNMENT
IS SO IMPORTANT TO EVERYONE'S
LIFE WHEN IT REALLY ISN'T.
ALSO JUAN, ONE MORE THING.
$5 BILLION IN A BUDGET THAT'S
WHAT, ALMOST $4 TRILLION?
IT'S NOTHING.
IT'S SYMBOLIC.
>> Juan: IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
WHEN HE NOT ONLY SAYS IT'S GOING
TO BE TRUMP SHUTDOWN WITHIN
ADMITS DEMOCRATS WANT BORDER
SECURITY AND HAVE VOTED FOR
BORDER SECURITY WHICH IS WHAT HE
DID, AGAIN HE UNDOES HIS TALKING
POINTS, JESSE.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT OH, WELL,
PEOPLE WITH DISEASE ARE COMING
THROUGH, TERRORISTS ARE COMING
THROUGH.
ALL OF IT PROVEN WRONG, AND YET
HE'S SITTING THERE SPOUTING
THIS.
>> Jesse: HOMELAND SECURITY
HAS VERIFIED THOSE THINGS.
>> Juan: THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
ANY TERRORISTS HAVE COME ACROSS
THE SEVEN BORDER.
>> Jesse: THERE'S BEEN
TERRORIST RELATED PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CROSSED THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND TIJUANA SAYS THERE ARE
DISEASES DOWN THERE WITH THE
CARAVAN.
I'M NOT DEMONIZING IT.
THAT'S JUST FACT.
>> Juan: WE ARE NOT SPREADING
DISEASE.
WE ARE SPREADING FALSEHOODS.
>> Jesse: GOOGLE, PEOPLE.
>> Juan: THE DRUMS THAT YOU
OFTEN CITE AND HE SAYS DRUGS ARE
COMING TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND EVERYONE SAYS NO, MOST DRUGS
COME THROUGH LEGAL PORTS OF
ENTRY.
>> Jesse: YOU WOULD KNOW,
JUAN, BECAUSE YOU SOUND LIKE
YOU'RE HIGH RIGHT NOW.
>> Greg: THE BOTTOM LINE,
PROCESS VERSUS CHAOS.
HE COMES OFF AS THE MEAN DAD.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THIS WHILE
I'M GOING TO SHUT DOWN, THAT'S
HOW DAD ACTS.
THE OTHER KIDS AND THEY ARE NOT
TAKING THE MEDICINE.
IT ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO THIS,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
CHUCK SCHUMER REMINDS ME OF A
VINTAGE PENGUIN FROM THE
ORIGINAL "BATMAN."
IT'S A COMPLIMENT.
>> Jesse: IT WAS REPORTED THAT
AFTER THE MEETING APPARENTLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD THEM THAT
IN THE NEW NAFTA MEXICO WILL
PLAY FOR THE WALL.
IT COULD STILL HAPPEN.
>> Morgan: THE MARKETS NEED
CALMING TODAY.
IT GOES TOGETHER.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN
HE'S WILLING TO TAKE POLITICAL
HITS.
HE'S WILLING TO TAKE THE
TERRIFIED TO CHINA.
I CAN SEE WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
HAPPY HE SAID THAT TODAY.